l'Outaouais, de Gatineau.
Bonsoir M. Prévost.
- Bonsoir M. Roy.
- Vous avez dit : "C'est comme
si on avait dérobé la Joconde
au Louvre à Paris puis on
l'avait remplacé par un faux."
C'est quelque chose qui est
quand même important à vos yeux.
- Bien, en fait, c'est presque
incroyable. Je dois vous dire
que quand j'ai appris
la nouvelle, je pensais
que c'était un canular.
Alors, j'ai communiqué
avec le Château L
qui ont confirmé la nouvelle.
Alors, on a un Arsène Lupin
en ville, parce que là on vient
d'apprendre que le vol
ne s'est pas produit
au cours des derniers jours,
mais des derniers mois.
Alors, c'est presque un crime
parfait où on voit qu'on ne
regarde pas très attentivement
les oeuvres, les fameuses
photographies de Karsh.
Vous l'avez dit en entrée,
c'est digne d'un film
et c'est vrai que,
naturellement, dans une autre
mesure, c'est comme si le
Louvre, on venait de découvrir
qu'on a volé la Mona Lisa, la
Joconde, et que personne
ne s'en est aperçu, et là
on parle de plusieurs mois.
Alors, c'est encore plus
incroyable.
-Bon, M. Prévost, dites-moi,
cette photo, ce portrait
remarquable de Winston Churchill
de Karsh, d'abord, redonnez-moi
le contexte. Ç'a été fait quand
et combien ça vaut une photo
originale comme ça?
- Alors, ça a été pris en
décembre 1941. Alors, on est
au coeur de la Seconde guerre
mondiale. Churchill, qui est le
premier ministre du Royaume-Uni,
est allé à Washington
parce qu'il voulait avoir
l'appui du président des
États-Unis. Les États-Unis
ne sont pas encore en guerre.
Et après, il est venu au Canada,
il est venu à Ottawa, pour
rencontrer le premier ministre
de l'époque Mackenzie King.
Et le Canada est l'un des
principaux alliés du Royaume-
Uni. Alors, il est invité
à la Chambre des communes
et après on demande à M.
Chuchill si on pouvait prendre
une photo. Et Churchill
ne voulait pas au départ,
mais finalement, c'est Yousuf
Karsh, qui a pris la photo,
et c'est une photo unique,
parce qu'on voit que
M. Churchill est de
très mauvaise humeur. Il faut
dire qu'il ne souriait pas
souvent, mais là il est
particulièrement bougon.
C'est parce que juste avant
de prendre la photo, Karsh l
enlevé son cigare, et là on voit
à quel point il est mécontent.
Et Karsh lui-même
cette photo-là avait changé
sa vie, puisqu'il va devenir
célèbre, il va d
un photographe, un portraitiste
de réputation internationale.
Et quand
personnalités, les rois,
les reines, les chefs d'État,
Einsteinle,le,le,le,le,le,le,
même le pape Jean-Paul II,
René Lévesque. Alors, quand on
venait  bien, il y
avait une tradition :
on allait se faire
Karsh.
- Et ça peut valoir combien?
- Bien, pour un archiviste
i, un historien,
ça n'a pas de valeur puisque
ça fait partie de notre
, de notre patrimoine
et c'est très relié aussi à
l'histoire du Château, puisqueKt
18 ans. Il a habité même
au Château Laurieravec sa secon.
Alors, pas une valeur
historique, patrimoniale,mais ut
que si on tente de vendre
mais un spécialiste diraitque se
cette photo aux enchères,
ça pourrait aller à environ50 Çr
monétaire de la photo.
Mais la valeur historique,patrit
inestimable. Et toute cette
histoire va faire, en plus,
augmenter la valeur de cette
photo. Depuis 1992, on ne peut
plus la reproduire.
Depuis que Karsh a fermé
ses studios, il n'y a plus
de droits de reproduction.
Cette photo a été reproduite
très souvent. Et les gens se
disent : s'il y a tant de
copies, pourquoi on s'en fait
tant? C'est l'originale.
Alors, quand on a cédé,
finalement, quand BAC,
Bibliothèque et Archives Canada
a acquis la collection, ce fonds
d'archives extraordinaire,
on cherche des originaux,
pas des copies.
- On va suivre ça. Je vous
remercie beaucoup de ce cours
d'histoire sur cette remarquable
photo qui trônait au Château
Laurier à Ottawa. Merci de nous
avoir parlé.
- J'espère qu'on va la
retrouve